I'm my wife and I are big American Idol
fans would go way back so I'm really
feeling a little star-struck clearly
squared C squared happening right now
there's a lot of personality sitting
here we are both actually very similar
you are well sexist and get along bubbly
yeah we both started on Idol yeah and I
have no idea until literally last night
that one of your audition songs was
since you've been gone
yes oh my gosh I didn't know that yes um
well oh well thank you no I remember
auditioning you know there's so many
different rounds before you even get to
even get to Paul Iranian summon which we
have the original three oh my gosh I
don't for nobody does it
I actually audition with the sweetest
thing yes Newton yeah went through to
the next round and then saying that won
again and I thought maybe this will be
good keep doing this one and I think it
was Paulo had asked me to sing something
could you sing something pop and I went
I just started singing your song no way
and I was terrified because you Pig I
would not be my go-to first person that
came to mine and then 20 seconds of
something else and so I think
broken-winged by Martina oh good song do
the same thing you know like I did luck
charm for me it got me through to the
next round
oh that's awesome they had all of us do
that though everybody thinks it's like
one song I just sing like three
different round again yeah I was like am
I still proving that I can sing on key
here like what's happening this is
amazing backstage dish we are spilling
the tea so we I heard we also have
something in common you eloped right my
husband I eloped
that's right got a whole plan oh my gosh
I stay yeah and then I don't know we are
we had this whole big wedding planned in
Nashville and the only thing we had
failed to do was send invitations out so
I'm looking at the Gateway and what so
this wasn't on purpose
you forgot to invite people no I'm
getting to it so we we we have this list
and I'm going hell I don't even like
half of these people and I don't even
know the rest
you know because you like this person
and that person and then you've got a
it's just got me this big exactly why
can't and it felt like a CMA afterparty
yeah I'm just like this big production
and it's supposed to be about your mom
now I live baby let's just a runaway
yeah you guys who thought you never
asked
we don't tell anybody and just ran off
that's so awesome he was sweet about it
that's perfect for us everybody has to
do what's right for them I will say you
had a very rare honeymoon location we
did here in Baghdad that's right well
that's the place to go no i-i've been
working with the USO for many years and
I was booked to go on one early January
so we said I do and then hopped on a
plane and flew over seas to rockin yeah
it's been our honeymoon there everybody
at each spot that we would stay at had a
honeymoon suite for us it was the
funniest thing we had a ball that we
would gosh it's so sweet that's cool
that you fallen through it is very
important they sacrifice a lot say what
you mean mean what you say and honor
your word
[Applause]
what about your wedding it all up or did
you have a big wedding we had a secret
wedding in our backyard with 25 people
and mostly people that were on your list
so there was some country music no we
just we had the same thing where we just
said you know what let's not do the big
to-do let's just keep it very small and
in fact it was a surprise wedding it was
the night before the Emmys and Megan was
nominated so we had her families come
and we just had him over and we said oh
by the way if you step into the backyard
this is our wedding we met doing a play
in Los Angeles I she was a couple years
into Will and Grace and I was living in
somebody's basement and she was like I'm
sick of classy individuals we find a
carpenter Kelly tell us about your movie
its mistletoe secret right hallmark yeah
I play a small-town girl from North
Carolina so it wasn't far of a stretch
yeah and I'm trying to save my little
town and bring small businesses help
them come back to life and and bring
tourists there there's a love interest
that comes into place of course nothing
it's so much drama because it's hallmark
you know ya know it's a sweet little
love story and I get to yeah they're
feel-good movies right
they all have happy endings I love life
I know right that's why my Christmas I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this